the initial character design for the
first sonic the hedgehog film was met
with overwhelming backlash in 2019 and
it seems like the video game turned film
was doomed however after being delayed
by paramount so the team could redesign
the titular blue hedgehog the film went
on to have a record setting opening
weekend now with two sequels and a
spin-off series on the horizon the
adaptation has successfully turned
things around the reception for the new
final trailer for sonic the hedgehog 2
is a whole lot warmer than the original
much maligned trailer with many fans
eager to see what's next for the
franchise jim carrey who seldom stars
and sequels will even be returning as
the evil mad scientist dr evo eggman
robotnik the upcoming adventure film
will follow sonic voiced by ben schwartz
as he faces off against avenge for
robotnik
this time though each has a partner in
crime tales voiced by colleen
o'shaughnessy and knuckles voiced by
idris elba if sonic and tails don't beat
robotnik and knuckles to the master
emerald it could mean the end of the
world with the stakes higher than ever
the final trailer for sonic the hedgehog
2 offers another glimpse of the
explosive search for this all-powerful
emerald here's what you might have
missed in the action-packed new trailer
sonic the hedgehog has always had a
rocking soundtrack in the newest trailer
for sonic 2 one of the first scenes
shows james marston's thomas wachowski
attending a wedding in hawaii but right
in the middle of the ceremony his phone
rings
so help me thomas sorry sorry
astute fans may have picked up on this
auditory cue but for the uninitiated the
ringtone is actually the music from the
first level of the original sonic video
game this little tune comes to us from
the green hill zone which was also
referenced in the first film as the town
sonic hides in green hills montana one
of the major driving forces of both the
sonic movies and video games are
mysterious stones known as chaos
emeralds in the trailer we see that dr
robotnik has discovered what he refers
to as a source of ultimate power which
is revealed to be the green chaos
emerald these particular gems within the
game series are imbued with fantastic
powers like time manipulation or the
ability to transform its holder into a
being of vast cosmic power as
illustrated by sonic's yellow third
iteration that is effectively
unstoppable in the video game sonic 3.
sonic wishes to protect the chaos
emeralds while dr robotnik wants to use
that power to remake the world in his
twisted image knuckles is the official
guardian of these powerful relics and
his tribe of anthropomorphic animals is
tasked with protecting them the trailer
sees dr robotnik use a chaos emerald to
power his army of machines while also
radiating the awesome power of the
emeralds himself which is illustrated by
the green arcs of lightning across his
body hopefully this means that we might
get a glimpse of super sonic at some
point in sonic 2. as long time sonic
gamers have been pointing out online
there's a moment in the new trailer that
is almost identical to a classic sonic
the hedgehog 2 level called the sky
chase zone in which tales and sonic
operate a red and white biplane dubbed
the tornado through various obstacles
and enemies in the new trailer we see
nearly a shot for shot recreation of it
with sonic even standing on top of the
plane's wings just like he does in the
game while sonic the hedgehog found a
place in the gaming world as sega's
answer to nintendo's mario it resembled
most early 90s games by focusing more on
the gameplay than the storyline
collecting golden rings and avoiding
obstacles all while going really fast
wasn't something that essentially needed
a story in those days however in a small
throwback moment from the new trailer
audiences were treated to a sweet call
back to the game that changed all of
that in a moment with epic slow motion
and an obligatory shout out to the mcu
oh great the winner soldier
sonic jumps from a cave at the top of a
mountain and uses a makeshift snowboard
to flee from pursuers when sonic jumps
on his board he lets out to recognizable
cheer
the exclamation goes back to 1998 with
the release of sonic adventure which was
the first to truly introduce 3d gameplay
the first to be story driven and the
first include a full voiceover including
sonic's little cheer
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]